why are you back there's a murder at my
favorite Denny's nice Hey that brings us
to our desk piece it's time for nice not
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
nice miniskirts in order to convince me
to stay at war general McMaster had to
show me an old photo of hot Afghan women
and miniskirts tallied in nice mini
fridges mini fridges have problems on
many sides on many sides you have to
bend down to use them
the fries are always ices up and the
shelves are too short for my KFC bucket
and the buckets the best part but show
me a mini fridge and a miniskirt and
frigid day super nice nice they pester
small children at summer camp and that's
my job ok still stay on topic what you
can't fire me I queef language that's my
favorite one I know it by heart
moving on nice status' the single best
way to preserve our precious precious
history not nice history it's all its
books and I wasn't there so who cares
besides people always say if you don't
learn it it just repeats itself so I'll
catch a rerun super duper not nice the
History Channel
it's all pawn stars and American Pickers
where's Hitler he used to be the whole
channel when I get home after a hard
morning I want to plunk down on my bare
mattress with a jug of wine and root for
Hitler you know what I need to unwind
Karen runs me a nice shallow bath that's
disgusting Mike I hope you drown in it
like a toddler
nice Hillary Clinton she called me a
creep for breathing down her neck during
the second debate but I'm not a creep
I'm in love I'm obsessed with her I
can't stop thinking about her
the only reason I wanted to see her
30,000 emails was because I was hoping
there was one in there that said she
loved me I don't like water but let me
do a nice that'll cheer yeah you know
what guys
working for a white nationalist website
then working inside the White House
while you say you stopped working at
that website but you never really okay
okay you go back to that website even
though you'll still be working for the
White House Steve without the shackles
of a gutless deep state okay keeping me
from using my dark sex magic in my war
against Google is secular murder he's
getting to attend the beast in the zone
no Dean I told you I never done sit down
he's a well I'm a witch
[Applause]
he's gone don't worry this happens all
the time he'll be back